sixty minutes has obtained horrifying
video of the aftermath of the sarin gas
attack on Syrian civilians last April a
warning these images graphically show
what happened in this chemical attack an
estimated 100 people died here 200
others were injured the video was not
shown publicly until Scott Kelly's
report last night these are the people
of a small farming town who called
concha who they fell after a warplane
dropped a bomb nearby they're civilians
there's no military target here but the
village does lie in territory held by
rebels fighting against the dictatorship
of Bashar al-assad there are reports of
another chemical attack in Syria this
time in the rebel-held eastern goota new
airstrikes hit the area this morning
even as the UN Security Council is
urging a ceasefire their death Donuts in
Lebanon near the Syrian border with the
latest on this story south good morning
good morning we are close to the border
with Syria the eastern suburbs of the
capital Damascus have been bombarded by
forces loyal to the Syrian government as
they try to regain control they're using
some of the most aggressive assaults of
the 7 year long war young children some
of them infants were treated at a
hospital inside rebel controlled doom up
in eastern goota while the intensity of
air strikes his lesson forces allied
with the Syrian government continued
bombing the Damascus suburb despite a UN
ceasefire brokered Saturday I was hit by
shrapnel all over this man said and my 9
year old son was killed the 30 day
ceasefire did not specify a start time
apparently the result of lobbying by
Syria's ally Russia it's estimated more
than 500 people including at least 130
children have been killed since this
latest assault began last week pictures
released over the weekend by syrian
activists show patients including
children apparently suffering from
symptoms consistent with a chlorine
attack the 16 patients
were being treated by the
syrian-american Medical Society
operating inside the rebel-held Damascus
suburb the Syrian government has always
denied using chemical weapons and their
Russian allies have accused rebels of
planning to use toxic materials to later
blame the government
Eastern goota has been described as hell
on earth it is estimated around 400,000
people are surrounded there by
government forces and this ceasefire is
designed to allow for much needed
humanitarian aid to be delivered and for
medical evacuations Nora all right Seth
Doane in Lebanon thank you